underneath the Christmas
tree yeah that was Vince Vance and the
Valiants I like
them what else Silver Bells stringing up
these
lights sorry guys I'm all over the place
um I'm happy I'm happy that I'm that
we're hitting the end of the
year uh the only by the only guy that's
got a lot left to do this year usually
is you know who I'm talking about your
boy Santa Claus son everybody this year
getting a OIC that's what Santa's just
Santa's been compromised bro I heard
it's just a dude just with a sleigh full
of OIC now that's what I heard it's just
some [__] white dude with a sigh full
of OIC bro and they got I heard they
paid up you know uh big Pharma paid the
North Pole enough they off work this
year
so you just got you know is just going
to be a zic
dealer and people's on those zic that's
bro that's that fat crack that's what
people calling it that fat cane
baby people don't know zimp
it people Lo you'll meet a dude he lost
1100 PBS bro in 45
minutes the times have changed man it's
a lean Christmas man it's just gonna be
a couple big farmer
reps uh just H just huming uh
injectables out of a damn
Cessna all around the world
man yeah I and that just the I don't
know if uh a zic seems safe man you'll
see somebody they're like yeah I'm 38
years old and uh I'm down to 55 lbs yeah
thank God I can fit into a lot of my
same clothes I wore in fourth grade yeah
my my skin makes a weird noise when I
smile but other than that man I'm
doing great they start [__]
glitching they just start you
know they're like I'm doing
great I I weigh
SBS I can't can't
remember who I
am my resting heart rate
is
two but I'm doing
well I'm doing
well I'm I'm doing
well I'm
[Music]
on then they start start burping you
ever talk to that OIC user you start
talking to him and then
just did it start blowing bubbl it's
like
some some dude you'll be talking to one
of those igu or they'll just [__] eat
a bug that flew by you're like what the
the [__] and then just the side effects
bro some OIC or oans or whatever they
call them these [__] they got some
side effects bro they're like I can't
close my eyes or I
will [__]
myself uh they're like I can't breathe
anymore but I'm doing good I lost
46 Pounds
I'm going to
heaven you're like what the [__] chill
out Melissa you need a [__] little
you need a smoothie Melissa you're
[__] losing your [__] people are
shooting up in their cars at
lunch and no shade there man I'm um I'm
just Clowning I'm not trying to hurt
nobody's feelings there but come F Bells
will be
ringing
M I can't bend my knees
anymore every dream I have has Katie
Perry in it but I'm doing better than
ever can somebody close my eyes for me
so I can get some
rest I ain't losing my mind I tried to
jump out of window to take my own life
but I only
weigh 177
o so I
just floated back down to
earth F Cube o zic has anyone seen my
children but then you have the alternate
guy you have the guy like man [__] imp
doesn't even [__] work you know I T
you know I've been on the [__] for two
years I gained 100 lbs man I gain aund
aund
aund 100 hot
hot nut nut pounds
man you know and then the guy blame his
wife my wife keeps [__] shooting the
[__] into me
and I'm [__] you
know and then the guy will lick his lips
for like 70
minutes you know and then pull a [__]
beautiful little gum drop out from under
his tongue or something or he'll keep a
damn uh but a scotch up in his mouth and
that he'd been sucking on that [__] you
know but yeah I think Santa's just
that's I don't know if Santa's gonna
make it this year I think he might have
been taking over by
uh by big farmer I wouldn't be shocked
but yeah wouldn't be surprised if
Santa's on the peptides everybody is we
all do things and try stuff
to want to be different feel different
um I'm just fascinated by the
uh you know I I I've known women who are
driving down to Mexico to get OIC or a
PE or whatever they got down there you
know oh homie you're gonna be [__]
skinny homie dog if you go to prison you
can
Just Right Between the Bars homie you're
out of there dog they got nothing on you
dog yeah that people didn't realize like
OIC is just [__] you're free homie VI
re they busted a lady with 60 grams of
fake OIC over there outside of a
Vineyard
Vines you know
[Music]
and all can do is pray for but still
it's this is real
[__] hope you enjoyed that video and you
can watch another and you can watch this
one you can watch this one different
options different choices some guy just
brings you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this
one